you've been taking bullets charging it
up with kinetic energy
you turned off the artificial gravity
everywhere but i'm here
it's quantum entanglement between the
quantum states of posner molecules in
your brains
do you guys just put the word quantum in
front of everything i gotta say
we do put the word quantum in front of
everything hi
i'm jim kikelius i'm a physics professor
at the university of minnesota
and the author of the physics of
superheroes
[Music]
that's a scene from the first guardians
of the galaxy movie
and as they're making their jailbreak
rocket
turns off the artificial gravity in the
space station so that everyone else
floats
and is unable to get their bearings
and they make their escape i told you i
had a plan
say you're in an elevator and in the
worst case scenario
the cables break and you start free
falling you're no longer feeling the
effects of gravity
it's as if you're weightless you could
start doing magic tricks to the other
people in the elevator say hey look at
this pipe and let go of the pipe and it
would just float there
because it's falling you're falling all
at the same rate
but if you're already standing on the
floor
you'd stay standing on the floor however
anyone who is
walking at the moment they were walking
they were pressing their feet down
on the ground and then lifting their
feet up
and at that moment if the gravity was
turned off they had would have launched
themselves
up and without gravity to slow their
ascent they would keep rising
in that way so the people who were
stationary and started to float up
not so much anyone who was walking would
indeed start to flow up
i'm not quite sure how the artificial
gravity is being generated
in the space station and the whole
notion of artificial gravity that can be
turned on and off at will
in generalized locations in the space
station
that's a bit too far talking raccoons
that part's okay
[Music]
my undying fidelity
[Music]
so thanos has just acquired the space
infinity stone
and as soon as he has this he's able to
stop loki's dagger thrust in mid-air
undying you should choose your words
more carefully
well there's actually some real physics
behind this back in the beginning
of the 20th century emmy nerder was able
to show a deep
intimate connection between space and
momentum
controlling the space stone not only
allows you to teleport but apparently
also gives you command
over momentum loki's dagger thrust is
arrested
and all the momentum is stopped if you
look closely around loki's arm you see a
little blue glow
that's coming from the space stone
that's arresting the momentum of his
thrust
it's worth noting that in captain
america the first avenger
the space stone which was embedded in
the tesseract at the time
is the only infinity stone that was
actually weaponized by hydra
and used to create force beams thereby
showing that there is indeed a
connection between space and momentum
[Music]
the first iron man movie 2008 the one
that started the whole marvel universe
i love it tony stark the superhero
as engineer and the engineer as
superhero when he
built his first suit it in a cave
out of scraps it was made of iron
and was very heavy at 150 pounds just
counting the iron not counting the
weaponry
then he developed the mark ii which was
titanium titanium is lighter than iron
and strong
and then in order to combat the icing
problem
used a gold titanium alloy
let's connect to the cisco have it
reconfigure the shell metals use the
gold titanium alloy from the serra from
tactical satellite that should ensure a
fuselage integrity while maintaining
power to weight
ratio got it now there are gold titanium
alloys
they tend to be very brittle they're
used in dental applications more than
anything else
so unless he's fighting you know crime
boss
gingivitis i don't think that he's
really would want to use a gold titanium
alloy
so much of the technology except for the
arc reactor
are things that we actually have right
now we have exoskeletons we have plating
we even have jet boots the one thing we
don't have is a power supply
he has an arc reactor that's about the
size of a hockey puck
and puts out the power of three nuclear
power plants if we knew how to do that
we wouldn't need superheroes because
otherwise you'd have an iron man suit
but you'd have to drag a long extension
cord behind you
in order to have enough power for the
suit one thing that's realistic
in this is that we never see him when he
engages his boots or
or shoots a repulsor ray we never see
him press a button
or give a voice command he thinks it and
it happens that's because he has a
cybernetic helmet
that picks up his thought waves and
sends the information to the suit
this is real scientists and engineers
at the university of minnesota and at
other universities
and institutions around the world are
developing cybernetic helmets
that pick up the very weak radio waves
that are generated when we think
amplifying them
sending them via bluetooth to another
device
they're trying to develop prosthetics
and treat paralysis
but if you had asked me as a kid when i
was reading iron man comics
which part in the 21st century would be
the closest to reality
the last thing i would have said was the
cybernetic helmet
[Music]
why don't you pick on someone your own
[Music]
size
ant-man shrinking down to the size of an
ant even much smaller
when ant-man shrinks he's also able to
control his mass
and he shrinks a constant density so
he's very lightweight when he rides on
an
ant for example he doesn't smush the ant
but when he wants to punch yellow jacket
he's able to increase his mass so
there's more force
more momentum behind his punch how does
he do it
in the comics and in the movie via pym
particles
that were discovered by hank pym if they
had just given a little bit of
of lip service to how the one changes
the size
of atoms they say that they're changing
the spacing between the atoms of the
space in the atoms
the size of an atom is determined via
quantum mechanics
to be the ratio of several fundamental
constants charge of an electron
mass of an electron planck's constant if
via the pim field
to adjust say the magnitude of planck's
constant
make it 10 times smaller then the atoms
would become
100 times smaller and the size of an
object
would shrink uniformly if you make it
ten times bigger
the size of the atoms would be a hundred
times bigger you could become giant man
[Music]
spiderman oh my gosh this is it tell
everyone
hang on oh yeah i see that looking class
a lot
so here peter parker spider-man needs to
stop a runaway elevated train
he shoots out multiple web lines they
stretch a great deal
but they don't break and he's able to
stop the train just in the nick of time
how strong does the webbing have to be
for this to work
we can look up the mass of a train
we can estimate its initial velocity by
seeing how long it takes to pass
city blocks we can look at the distance
over which the the webbing stretches
we can estimate its diameter we can
count the number of web lines
and we come up with a tensile strength
for the webbing
that has to be about a thousand
megapascals
which is equivalent to 145 000 pounds
per square inch
but real spider silk has a tensile
strength
of 1200 megapascals if spider-man's
webbing
is anywhere as strong as real spider
silk then this indeed
could happen he's shooting it out of his
wrists which is not what a real spider
would do
but we'll just leave that aside
dr strange is a deviation from all the
other marvel movies
in so far as everything else in the
marvel cinematic universe
up till then had some sort of hand wavy
super science type explanation but here
they're going for just full-on magic
this doesn't make any sense not
everything does
not everything has to the notion that
there are multiple dimensions
is an idea that has been taken seriously
by at least some physicist
what if i told you the reality you know
is one of many quantum mechanics
is the branch of physics that describes
the properties of atoms
and how they interact with light one
aspect of quantum mechanics that many
scientists find troubling is that it
only deals with probabilities
so you can calculate the probability of
a measurement
giving the electron at a certain
location in space and time
but not exactly where that electron will
be one
alternative explanation is that there
are actually
an infinite number of parallel universes
you find the electron at one location
but in other universes it might be in
some different location
so presumably maybe doctor strange is
visiting some of these parallel earths
that have undergone significant quantum
deviations
from our own as far as the science there
even if they're in a parallel earth
the fact that their antagonists are able
to affect
the orientation of gravity locally i'm
sorry that's just magic but he's the
master of the mystic arts so i'll give
him a break
[Music]
now i don't know what you plan on doing
here i've come here to put an end to
loki's schemes
and prove it put that hammer down uh
yeah no
bad call he loves you you want me to put
the hammer down
thor puts the hammer down on captain
america's shield
in the movies the shield is made of pure
vibranium where in the comics it's an
alloy of steel and vibranium
that's actually more realistic you want
steel
provide strength and rigidity so that
when captain america throws its mighty
shield
it will ricochet but you want the
vibranium because it
absorbs all vibrations making it the
perfect shock absorber
as it's absorbing thor's hammer blow in
the scene
it's completely vibration absorbent
energy can't be destroyed it can only be
converted to another form
the energy of the hammer strike is
converted into
sound waves in the hammer and if the
vibranium absorbs it
what form does it take what we see from
the clip
it's converted into blue light
ultraviolet light
this enormous flash of light that's
given off
it's showing that the vibranium is
actually
a perfect sonoluminescent material
sono meaning sound luminescent meaning
light you
send sound waves in and you get light
out this is a real phenomenon in physics
the only real difference is that
vibratium
unfortunately doesn't exist
[Music]
you're linked to janet it's quantum
entanglement between the quantum states
of posner molecules in your brains
do you guys just put the word quantum in
front of everything this is
a classic example of quantum
mumbo jumbo there are some real words
and real concepts
that we use there but they're used in a
context
or in connection with other phrases that
i just cannot follow
but quantum entanglement is a real thing
if you bring two objects so close
together
that their quantum wave functions
overlap then they can only be described
as a single two object quantum wave
function
and if i bring them very far apart and i
don't
disentangle them then they remain
connected
so something that's done on this end
shows up in the other end
even though they could be on opposite
ends of
the earth or opposite ends of the solar
system
they would still be communicating to
each other because they're still
described by one single wave function
scientists are using this property of
entangled quantum states
to try to see if they can develop
superior computers
they're trying to make the context for a
character in the movie a ghost
who is quantum mechanically tunneling
through solid objects
a real phenomena but the way they're
doing it
just doesn't really make sense a little
bit too much quantum woo
so i'd say less woo more quantum
[Music]
i'm
so here we see the black panther
and his sister scientific genius shuri
she's using a holographically
generated car in wakanda
to steer a car the black panther has
commandeered
in south korea which side of the road is
sick
just right okay calm down
what makes wakanda special is that it's
near
inexhaustible supply of vibranium an
extraterrestrial mineral
that has the ability to absorb all
vibrations
the hard light hologram always used to
bother me
holograms are interference patterns
created
with light the hologram itself is not an
actual object
it is an image but i thought about it
some more using
sound you can create regions that
have a pressure and exert a force as if
they were a solid object
and presumably if you overlay that with
a optical hologram you would have
something
that feels solid but is generated via
light
presumably using their command of
vibranium shuri is able to do this
and overlay it with an optical hologram
which has
no solidity but still produces a visual
image
for her to interact with i don't know if
i could create a interference sound
pattern
overlaid with a hologram to create a
hard
light object but surely someone can
[Music]
show off
[Music]
surprising absolutely no one here we see
carol danvers captain marvel
showing up in avengers end game
obviously responding to the sos call
sent out by nick fury
at the end of avengers infinity war we
last saw her
in the mid-1990s at the end of her own
movie captain marvel
where she took off into outer space to
try to find the skrulls
uh homeworld she comes back to earth 24
25 years later doesn't appear to be any
older
einstein's special theory of relativity
says that all observers whether
stationary or moving
have to agree on the value of the speed
of light
for that to be the case they will
disagree about distances
and disagree about times there is an
effect called time dilation
that if someone is moving very close to
the speed of light to a stationary
observer
time will appear to have been moving
slower say she spent six months
traveling close to but not at the speed
of light
then six months traveling at this
velocity
would correspond to 24 years passing on
earth
we don't know what's going to happen in
captain marvel 2
but if any of it involves traveling
near the speed of light then the time
dilation effect could easily account
for the fact that she doesn't appear to
have aged significantly from the last
movie
[Music]
this has been jim cacallius your
friendly neighborhood physics professor
and in the words of the legendary stan
lee
face front true believer what's the
matter with you kids you've never seen a
spaceship before
bring them over here and hold on for
safekeeping
that is hilarious